cette structure métallique installée
dans le fab lab de l'estaca est assez
familière pour ce groupe d'étudiants
il s'agit de l'ancien logo de l'école
d'ingénieurs qui à leur époque en 1969
était situé à paris
cinquante ans après le réseau estaca à
l'umih a organisé une visite du campus
de montigny le bretonneux
on a connu la rue bout de bruit ou salée
d'un cinquième arrondissement il y avait
quatre salles de cours et autres
or quand on voit ici là le volume le
confort le matériel installé ses
résultats je pense qu'on n'a pas trop
mal travaillé à l'époque pour développer
cette activité
en plus des locaux cette visite a
également été l'occasion de découvrir
les projets portés par les actuels
étudiants
exemple avec l'association pv 3e qui
conçoit un véhicule capable de parcourir
le plus de kilomètres avec un seul litre
d'essence
c'était très intéressant de voir des
étudiants qui sont qui étaient là avant
nous qui connaissent bien le lit déçu
relations qu on travaille ça vient là où
ils peuvent être les gains ils ont parlé
des roulements de l'aérodynamisme des
pertes moteur donc ils voyaient qui
connaissait bien le sujet après
l'obtention de leur diplôme en juillet
1969 certains ont embrassé une carrière
dans l'automobile d'autre dans
l'aéronautique
ils ont malgré tout toujours gardé
contact on s'est toujours but a toujours
vues autour d'eux au cours de notre vie
du coq
quelles que soient les endroits où on
était dans le nord de la france ou même
à l'étranger on est toujours on a
toujours trouvé les moyens de chaloupes
de jours
une expérience qu'il serait prêt à
renouveler ça peut être en fauteuil
roulant la prochaine fois on espère
[Musique]